Let's go next to our caller from country code
forty nine.
Country code 49.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
Hi, David.
My name is Corey.
I'm calling from from I live in Heidelberg,
Germany, but I'm on vacation.
And Mathen, Germany, which is the northwest
corner, which is about 10 minutes from the
Netherlands.
Right.
That sounds nice.
How what's the situation there from the standpoint
of the virus?
I'm actually in Istanbul and we're looking
at a sports bar, drinking a beer, and I'm
looking at families separated from each other.
And yeah, it's kind of weird because we decided
to take this jump because we've been stuck
in a lot, really stuck in our house.
But, you know, we've been playing it safer
since mid-March since you guys have.
Yeah.
And, yeah, we decide to take do it and we're
here and we're you know, we're doing what
we can.
We wear masks when we can.
But, you know, Germany is doing quite well.
You had five, I think six that's yesterday.
And, you know, that sounds terrible.
You're going to be when you say, oh, you had
five or six deaths, but you know what I'm
saying?
Yeah.
The U.S. had thirteen hundred yesterday.
So it's a dramatic difference.
Yes.
Right.
So I. I been listening to you since the Joe
Rogan part.
We've and Joe Rogan a couple times, but I'm
a big fan.
He's been on a set that really makes me you
every Dadge.
I wouldn't you either jog every day and just
I agree with so much of your your energy and
your soul and where you're coming from.
And I'm so happy that I got a Twitter notification
today and I'm on vacation, but I've got to
call him because it's the first time I've
ever found out when to call.
Right.
Really, what I went to court what I want to
tell you was that we're doing good here.
I'm actually going to the Netherlands tomorrow
to do some shopping.
Come back across the border.
There's no restrictions.
Everything's wide open.
We're doing fine here.
I don't feel you know, I'm super nervous about
everything in United States right now.
I worked for I worked for as a contracted
employee with NATO.
And I and I know I think I understand your
feelings about, you know, the military presence
or a police stay across the world.
I think I have a pretty good understanding
of your take on that.
But what what what you really got me scared
is, you know, obviously that he wants four
more years, but it's I could lose my job over
this this whole thing with, you know, just
being pissed off, this miracle.
I'm going to take everybody out because I
don't like her.
I mean, take everybody out of out of Germany.
Put the man who knows where he wants to put
them.
I think it's just a veiled threat at this
point.
But I've never really understood your feeling
about NATO as a whole.
You've never really expressed that.
I never really heard you say it.
I know that you're against it, quote unquote.
Police state.
But how do you feel about NATO in general?
I don't have any particular problem with the
idea of organizations like NATO.
I think the devil is in the implementation,
but I think in a theoretical framework, shared
defense agreements are reasonable.
They make sense.
We have an increasingly globalized world.
You know, we often say at the country level
there are some problems that are too big for
anybody but government to solve.
And that's why libertarian ideas sort of fall
short, like there are some things, big regulatory
things, that you just need the power of government.
When you've got a multi multibillion dollar
corporation, government is what you need in
order to regulate it.
And even beyond that, when you have multinationals
and problems that span across multiple countries,
you need some kind of higher infrastructure
and something NATO like is fine.
That doesn't mean I necessarily agree with
everything NATO does or every every one of
NATO's actions, including, you know, we could
go back to the Clinton era or whatever, but
I've no problem with with frameworks like
NATO in principle.
Yeah, I think I think I get your feeling on
that.
It's it's just for me, it's just such a it's
like two or three year old tantrum right now
with young men with Trump against America.
Well, that's what that's what bothers me the
most.
It's it's so catty.
And yeah, there's there's issues with NATO
for sure.
But, you know, I'm married to a German lady
and I've been here for ten years since 2005
off.
No, I'm at a total of ten years.
And I just bought a house here.
And I I'm sort of stuck with what's happening
stateside.
So I'm pretty much making my life here at
this point.
I was I was really moved back.
I had all these plans to move back in 2016.
And then it just yeah, it's just it's my mindset.
It's completely shifted and sadly, it's shit.
We had already planned on moving back.
But anyway, David, I mean, listen to you every
day.
I would, because in new conversation with
you, you're doing great thing.
Turn you into a.
People keep doing the great work.
All right.
Corey from Germany, thank you.
I appreciate the kind words and the phone
call from Germany.